au fond du parc de l'entreprise shiseido
située au nord d'orléans trône une
dizaine de ruches dont une bien
particulière bertrand laurentin a mis au
point un boîtier rempli de capteurs qui
se greffent sous la ruche avec cette
promesse faite aux apiculteurs connaître
en temps réel la santé de leurs abeilles
elles sont petites
la ruche et géolocalisés et on a le
poids de la ruche son orientation avec
les capteurs de luminosité et la
température l'humidité tout un tas
d'indications qui nous dit si les
abeilles vont bien si elle produit du
miel ou pas l'apiculture métier
artisanal par excellence
peut-il être compatible avec les
nouvelles technologies pour denis pioger
apiculteur dans le loiret à l'heure du
tout connecté
l'intérêt est réel pour la profession
vit longtemps puisque sinon on est vite
dépassé donc je pense que c'est u2 une
bonne chose de d'évoluer
et puis d'utiliser toute la technologie
qui nous qui nous permet d'avancer dans
ton métier avec la belle abeilles
l'objectif du jeune entrepreneur or les
années et multiple d'une part lutter
plus efficacement contre la disparition
massive des butineuses mais également
favoriser l'emploi local
des arguments qui ont séduit des
entreprises comme orange ou shiseido
toutes les deux ont accepté d'installer
des ruches connectés dans leur parc
ça rentre tout à fait dans la politique
de l'entreprise de protection de
l'environnement protection de la
biodiversité puisqu'on vient protéger
des abeilles qui a un rôle majeur on l'a
vu dans la pollinisation des plantes et
le maintien de la biodiversité donc ça
c'est une une constante dans le groupe
shiseido de développer des produits en
tenant compté en préservant les
ressources naturelles
aujourd'hui on a un projet donc
2 500 startups à aider jusqu'à en 2018
est donc aujourd'hui sur la région
centre
c'était très intéressant de travailler
avec la belle abeilles sur ce sur ce
projet il y a beaucoup d'applications
mobiles qui arrivent beaucoup de choses
de service et aujourd'hui on n'a pas
toutes les idées et donc des sociétés
des petites start-up qui on imagine des
solutions comme la belle abeilles on
n'aurait pas imaginé ce genre de choses
c'est ici au fab lab d'orléans sorte de
pépinière pour start up que bertrand
laurentin à concrétiser son idée de
ruches connectés relier un site web ou
une application mobile
le boîtier propose plusieurs
fonctionnalités sur l'interface on va
pouvoir regarder le poids de la ruche
qui va nous indiquer et quelle est la
quantité d'abeilles et de miel au coeur
de la rue ces données on va pouvoir
certes les vérifier sur le terrain ça
remplace pas une intervention humaine on
est arrivé à un être vivant donc il faut
intervenir surveiller vérifier sa
demande des notions apicole mais quand
on n'a pas ces notions apicole va
l'interface propose des conseils en
fonction des données qui sont renvoyés
par la rue maintenant que son produit
est opérationnel bertrand laurent espère
trouver rapidement des investisseurs
pour passer à la phase
d'industrialisation